what's up bro you lost what's up man oh
sorry I was just grabbing a charger dude
I'm with you your boys are Sean
Ethan and Dave right yeah yeah I work
with them sucks for you I went to
college with those retards huh
it's crazy
uh I'm gonna grab it I was considering
playing baseball in college but I was
like that dude I'd rather party and
chill and I'm not trying to cheat a
drug test every week
true all right I'm gonna head back in I
honestly was the best decision of my
life I joined a frat could hook up with
any Chick I wanted to why can't I mean
the craziest what do you do for
work by the way my dad wants me to work
with him but I'm like bro he just loaded
though and has a hot wife help
they're never gonna hear you
you're never gonna get out of here we're
going to converse until I've harnessed
all of your energy soon all the girls
will be gone all the drinks will be gone
and your friends will be in an Uber on
the way home and it'll be you and
you are remember
thank you